Transcriber: Bashar Al-Thawabta
المدقّق: Tarek Mamdouh
في 2018
قررت أن أصعد أعلى قمة في أفريقيا
جبل كليمنجارو
كيف؟
أتوقع ألا .
حلو.
طبعا قررت أني أصعد هذا الجبل
بسبب هذه الفترة من حياتي.
كنت في حالة من التوتر
وأيضا لم أكن راضية
بالحياة التي كنت عايشتها
كانت عبارة عن عمل وعبارة عن عائلتي وبس
فبالنسبة لي لم تكن الحياة الكافية لي،
وكنت أتمنى أن يوم
من الأيام سوف أصل لهدف حياتي كما هو.
ايش هو؟ ما اعرف
كان مكتوب على إعلان الجبل
إذا صعدت هذا الجبل سوف يغير حياتك إلى
الأبد .
فقررت أن أسجل وأصعد الجبل.
والمرشد السياحي قال لي
نور
سوم تسجسلك للصعود على الجبل
هو اليوم سوف يتغير حياتك مائة وثمانين درجة
ليس للوصول إلى الجبل بالنفس ولكن اللحظة
التي سجلت فيها للجبل حياتي تغيرت.
فإن عبارة عن تدريب صدفة .
أركض فجأة ، أشارك بسباقات، اشيل اثقال
الي صار إنه حياتي تمحورت
حول أنني أتدرب فقط لهذا الهدف
وأيضا كان يجب أن أجهز للأغراض
التي ألبسها ، فاضطررت أن أطلع وأسافر
وأشتري الأشياء التي أحتاجها .
وصلت للجبل .
تعرفت على ناس جدد، لكل منا
أهداف مختلفة ولكن كنا نريد أن نصعد هذا
الجبل ونوصل للقمة .
بدأنا أول شيء .
بين الأدغال وبعده دخلنا بين الصحاري
ودخلنا في الوديان وأخر شيء نصل للجليد
خلال المشوار .
طبعا مشوار هادئ لمدة سبعة ايام .
ستة ايام صعود واخر يوم .
وصلنا اليوم الرابع .
اليوم الرابع منهكين جدا .
كنا جدا تعبانين
كان لدينا توتر كان لدينا خوف
لماذا ؟ لأننا وصلنا الى ارتفاع على
ارتفاع أربعة الاف فوق سطح البحر .
هذا الارتفاع بالنسبة لأجسامنا
شيء غير طبيعي .
لأن نسبة الأكسجين أكسجين عندنا أساسا
سوف ينزل على هذا الارتفاع .
فكنا تعبانين جدا .
كنا نحاول التأقلم مع الارتفاع الجديد .
لحظتها المرشد توتر خوفنا .
وكنا شكنا في استمرارية هذا المشوار .
قال نور لا تفكرين في الأيام القادمة
ولا تفكرين في يوم القمة .
فقط ركزي على اليوم الذي أنت فيه .
وعلى الهدف لليوم .
عيشي اليوم بيومه لكي تستمتعين بالمشوار .
تستمتعين باللحظات التي ستعيشها
في كل يوم لهذا الجبل .
وبالفعل طبقت هذا الشيء .
صرت أعيش كل يوم بيومه .
تعبه بإرهاق بجماليته
كل شيء لدرجة أني وصلت لمرحلة
نسيت يوم القمة تماما .
وصلنا اليوم القمة .
وأنا لم استوعبه .
فالمرشد قال أنت اليوم ستصل للقمة
ستنامون العصر وتصحون في الليل .
أنا قلت لماذا ؟ لماذا اليوم
يعني كان يوم القمة .
فأنا انصدمت .
جتني صدمة .
كيف صار ؟ متى صار مثل حقنا ومتى وصلنا ؟
بس يوم وصلت لها
ذاك اليوم وصلت بأريحية أكبر .
وبثقة أكبر .
وصلت يعني بشكل أني أنا اليوم
مستعد أن أصعد الجبل .
فبدأنا على ضوء القمر نمشي خطوة
بخطوة قولة قولة على قولتهم .
ووصلنا إلى القمة .
طبعا لحظتها مصعب قلت أوكي
وصلت معنا فلا خلصنا صح .
ما حسست بأشي تاني غير أنا وصلت
للقمة  واتصورت والحين أنزل .
ففي مشوار النزول من الجبل
بدأت أستوعب ما فعلت شوي شوي
ليس مرة واحدة ولكن شوي شوي.
شعرت أنه حين أنا تدربت كل هذه الشهور
، كل هذا حتى هذه اللحظة .
لا طلع الموضوع كتير أكبر
من أنه أنا وصلت للقمة .
طلع الموضوع .
أنا حياتي أساسا تغيرت من يوم أنا
قررت أن أصعد هذا الجبل .
فقد تعلمت عدة أشياء من هذا المشوار
الذي قضيته خلال هذا الجبل .
الشيء الأول الذي تعلمته أنه يجب أن نعيش
اليوم بيومه مهما كان الهدف كبير .
وضع أهداف صغيرة أو مصغرة على أن نؤديها
خلال اليوم لكي نصل للهدف الكبير .
هذا الشيء الأول تعلمت .
الشيء الثاني أن لازم نمشي
بخطوات جدا بطيئة .
على أساس تتعلم من خلال هذا المشوار .
وأيضا نكسب أكثر ما نقدر
خلال مشوار لأهدافنا .
والشيء الثالث الي تعلمته .
الإنسان أحيانا ليس دائما على حسب الشخص .
من الجيد على الانسان ان يضع نفسه
بين الحياة والموت
لأن هذه البيئة ستغير حياتك
وتجعلك إنسان جديد
او تغير تفكيرك من الداخل إلى الخارج
وستغير حياتك من كل النواحي .
هذه النقطة الثالثة التي تعلمتها طبعا بعد
ما رجعت استوعبت أنه صار عندي شغف جديد
وأهداف جديدة .
قررت أني اصعد أعلى قمة في
كل قارة وهي سبع قمم .
وبدأ مشواري من بعد ما صعدت جبل كليمنجارو .
قدرت .
فقررت أني أصعد السبع قمم حول العالم
وقدرت أوصل أعلى قمة في أوروبا التي هي قمة
البروز .
وبعدها قدرت أنني أوصل أيضا قمم أخرى في
النيبال ومن بينهم وصلت إلى قاعدة الغرس .
إن شاء الله هذا سيكون الحلم
الأكبر لكي نشتغل عليه .
وأيضا لم اصل للقمة
ولكن حاولت أن أصعد
أعلى قمة في جنوب أمريكا طبعا ستكون
ما شاء الله هذه صعدت كل هذه الجبال
ولكن أنا ما وصلت لكل القمم في هذه الجبال
وصلت وفي بعضهم ما وصلت .
طبعا شخص يمر في ظروف أحيانا في مشواره
لكن مش راح أن للهدف من أول مرة هناك شيئان
واحد تتحكم فيهم في الجبل الجو
وأيضا مرض الارتفاع
وأنا عشت هذا الشي مرتين
ولكن تعلمت الكثير واكتسبت معارف
واكتسبت أشياء جديدة في حياتي من خلال
مشواري لهذه الجبال .
طبعا .
رجعت فجأة أرض الواقع ورجعت سطح البحر .
وقمت اطبق كل الذي تعلمته وذكرت لكم
بأن يومي أيامي تغيرت
حياتي مئة وثمانين درجة
صرت أطبق كل الذي تعلمته في حياتي .
في وظيفتي .
في ترقيتي أخذت وقتي في ترقيتي
وأيضا في
مشاريعي الحالية أشتغل عليها مع الناس
الذين تعرفت عليهم خلال المشوار .
رسالتي هي إذا عندك هدف كبير
في حياتك وإذا ما كان .
أمشي خطوة فخطوة بولي بولي وسوف تصل لهدفك .
فوق ما تتصور.